The Hydra of mythology was a massive monster.
If you cut off one of its heads, two more
would grow back in its place, and its teeth
had the power to raise skeletons.
It lived in the lake of Lerna in the Argolis.
We found our Hydra at a shopping mall.
See, hydras are microanimals found in freshwater
around the world, often attached to duckweed
and wood floating on unpolluted ponds and
streams.
And while James, our enterprising master of
microscopes, does often collect his various
microbial samples from the great outdoors,
in Poland where James lives, the ponds and
rivers are too cold most of the year for hydras.
But he’d heard that hydras are a problem
for aquarium owners, thus a trip to the mall.
This is the first hydra he found.
The microcosmos is a many splendored thing,
and sometimes what it uncovers is a toxin-tentacled,
potentially immortal hunter hitching a ride
on an aquatic snail inside a shopping mall aquarium.
The good news is, it doesn’t have any teeth
so I think we’re safe from the skeletons.
Hydra belong to the phylum Cnidaria, which
makes them a relative of jellyfish and sea anemone.
Their bodies are small, about 10-20 millimeters
in length, and also quite simple, composed
of two cellular layers around a central cavity,
which acts sort of like the hydra’s stomach.
At the end of this cavity, the hydra’s body
gives way to tentacles, which surround the
hydra’s mouth.
Like our snail-bound friend from earlier,
hydras usually secure themselves to hard surfaces,
including stones and bits of plants.
There, the hydra waits for food, its tentacles
stretching up to three times the length of
its body in search for prey like crustaceans,
insects, and even small fish.
Much of the hydra’s hunting ability lies
in those tentacles, which are armed with little
projectile cellular capsules called nematocysts.
Here, you can see some nematocysts that were
discharged by a hydra, which happened due
to mechanical stimulation of the nematocysts
as the sample was being prepared.
The cylindrical body of the nematocyst is
attached to a long thread, which can serve
different functions.
One type of nematocyst is equipped with a
thread that is designed to wind around the
hydra’s prey, while the thread of another
kind of nematocyst has an opening at the tip,
which allows it to puncture the surface of
the hydra’s prey to inject a neurotoxin.
When prey brushes up against the hydra’s
tentacles, the nematocysts are discharged
quickly, and by quickly, I mean very fast.
They experience around 5,410,000 g of force
in as little a time as 700 ns.
That incredible speed helps the thread of
the nematocyst act like a harpoon and catch
its prey.
When the hydra isn’t feeding, its mouth
is sealed with the rest of its body in a continuous
sheet of cells.
So to eat, the hydra essentially has to tear
a hole open in its body to let the prey in,
which it does by sending neuronal signals
that stretch the mouth apart until finally,
it rips open.
Even more remarkable, hydras can open their
mouths wider than their body, which lets them
eat prey that is bigger than them.
Inside the hydra, the prey is broken down
into particles that are taken up by surrounding
digestive cells.
Now hydra, let’s just get this out of the
way, don’t have an anus, so the remaining
undigested bits of food go out the same way
they came in: through the mouth.
You may have noticed that the hydras we’ve
shown are either brown or green.
You may have guessed, based on occurrences
of the color green in previous episodes, that
it suggests something about chloroplasts.
Indeed, green hydra—which are their own
distinct group called Chlorohydra—are occupied
by unicellular algae, which take up residence
inside of vacuoles within the hydra’s cells,
performing photosynthesis and providing sugars
in exchange for other nutrients and protection
from the hydra.
Hydras have fascinated biologists for centuries
thanks to their spectacular regeneration abilities.
They can withstand all manner of violence:
cut a hydra in two, and you’ll end up with
two hydras.
Cut it into twenty pieces, and you’ll have
twenty hydras.
Turn the hydra inside-out, and it will recover.
Scientists have even blended hydras down to
their cellular components, spun them in a
centrifuge so they pack together, and watched
as the cells sort themselves back into hydra.
For the organism, this all boils down to a
unique ability to continuously renew their
body through stem cells, which is why hydra
are sometimes called the eternal embryo.
This is not to say that they cannot die—if
food runs low or water quality becomes poor
or something eats them, then yes, the hydra
too will succumb.
But scientists studying hydra over several
years have found no sign of aging in the organisms,
which means that barring all of those challenges
we mentioned earlier, hydras may be immortal.
But as mortal beings ourselves, the possibility
of hydra’s immortality will likely remain
just that to us—an unconfirmed likelihood.
The simplicity of the hydra’s body belies
the complexity of its life, from algal symbionts,
to its periodically torn-open mouth, to its
endless renewal and regeneration.
All this, from an organism we found in a shopping
mall aquarium.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James, check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
Thank you so much to all of our patrons on
Patreon for helping make this show possible
and better every episode.
If you want to sign up, check out patreon.com/journeytomicro.
And if you want to subscribe to this channel, there’s always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.